Jake is adding superhero to his
impressive resume playing Mysterio in
the new Superman far from home but what
else is impressive his voice
[Music]
Maggie is the best as she has always
been yeah I'm the younger sibling it
right okay I may have gotten carried
away but Jake joining the Marvel
Universe is a big deal although he did
have Scouts I was a little worried about
the bubble ultimately also the suit is
sick and then you wore it for breakfast
on your Instagram really like that was
the helmet that I practiced and trained
in so you don't want any part of this
doping right he can't blow no cover
please Ryan and Jake were best friends
until recently when Ryan posted this
photo alongside Hugh Jackman on
Instagram saying happy best friends day
to Jake Gyllenhaal not pictured I used
to talk to move a lot until a couple
weeks ago but it was the sexiest Avenger
well I know that one spider-man
sexy is it man yeah he said spider-man
is the sexiest event that's true it's so
spare me sexiest Avenger
[Music]
I'm not gonna I'm not Martin you're
gonna vote for yourself I would do yeah
I would do yeah absolutely
[Music]